Exxon CEO Rex Tillerson Trump's incoming
Secretary of State was grilled yesterday
by republican florida senator marco
rubio going off on tillerson in a way
that usually same party committee
members don't go after nominees
tillerson of course a longtime chief of
ExxonMobil big time business dealings in
Russia Marco Rubio inquiring about
tiller sins view of Vladimir Putin let's
take a look at the first clip here let
me ask you this question is Vladimir
Putin the war criminal I would not use
that term well let me describe the
situation in Aleppo and perhaps that
will help you reach that conclusion so
then Rubio goes off for about a minute
or so reading a long list of stuff that
Putin has allegedly been involved in and
then he goes back to Tillerson again and
they have the following exchange at
August of that year it was at
seventy-eight percent in just three
months so based on all this information
and what's publicly in the record about
what's happened but on the Russian
military you are still not prepared say
that Vladimir Putin is military have
violated the rules of war and have
conducted war crimes in Aleppo those are
very very serious charges to mate and I
would want to have much more information
before reaching a conclusion I
understand there is a body of record in
the public domain I'm sure there's a
body of record in the classified domain
and I think in order in order to deal
with a serious question like this
citizen power level of the pub Melvin
Lane the video extras in alien form
before advising presidents well I
encourage you there's so much of it
there is so much information out there
about what's happening a lot go leaving
the Chechen issue aside what happened
there is clearly documented as well
there's so much information out there so
is there a simple answer to whether
Vladimir Putin is or isn't a war
criminal I mean in the literal sense
Putin is not a war criminal because he
hasn't been designated one by any
tribunal or been formally convicted of
war crimes this is like saying is
someone a murderer well no because they
haven't been found guilty of murder even
though they might have actually murdered
someone in the colloquial sense
colloquially speaking though based on
his actions Putin is probably a war
criminal he was an agent of the secret
police that
mass killings dating back to 1975 when
Putin joined when he came to power in
1999 he approved and maybe even
orchestrated bombings of two apartment
buildings in Moscow which led to
hundreds of innocent russian deaths and
then used the bombings to start the
second chechen war which produced
thousands of refugees he was involved in
the funding and aiding of Russian and
pro-russian terrorists in Ukraine award
that has taken ten thousand lives it's a
very long list but there's really no
advantage Pat for Tillerson to say yes
Vladimir Putin is a war criminal no
matter how close he is with Russia and
of course that's what's underlying this
right our concerns about the closest
with Russia the Tillerson has it's not
really advantageous for him to say yes
he's not Secretary of State and you
could make the case that this is Rubio
grandstanding to which I would say is
Rubio going to vote no because all of
this nonsense doesn't really mean much
unless Rubio says based on his answers
I'm not voting to confirm him that's the
thing because the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee has a makeup of I
guess 21 people 11 Republicans and 10
Democrat and if the Democrats all
Martian long steps blocks up against
this appointment Rubio would be the
deciding vote hypothetically that is
indeed the case and that's really what
is going to matter to me now there's
also way more that was disturbing from
this hearing including tillerson said as
I mentioned in our interview earlier he
doesn't view climate change as an
imminent national security threat
islands are going underwater as we speak
because of climate change if that's not
a national security threat I don't know
what is Tillerson is not against TPP he
said he doesn't oppose the agreement but
that he has some concerns about it like
Donald Trump has the concern here really
is number one killer sins views on some
of these issues are absolutely deranged
but also Tillerson doesn't agree with
Donald Trump on some really major issues
another one whose nukes for example
Trump said during the campaign it
wouldn't be bad if some additional
countries had nukes tillerson said that
he disagrees with Trump about that so on
the one hand there's concern because of
what Tillerson believes we also have no
idea what the policy of the trump
administration will be because Tillerson
and Trump seem to disagree about so much
my last thought about this and every
every of the most likely scenario is
that Rex Tillerson will be our next
Secretary of State how sad will it be to
go from John Kerry a well-spoken
intelligent knowledgeable Secretary of
State to basically an oil redneck who
will do business with anybody that's
willing to let him drill in their
country yeah and how bizarre is it that
we have a CEO of Exxon becoming the next
Secretary of State it usually it's some
politician or someone who is well
respected within the diplomatic
community right now we're moving on to
an oil tycoon absolutely shameful Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial calm / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker calm /
TDPS it costs nothing